oh yeah there's there's a secret setting
I don't know if I should share my
secrets but secret setting animation
type I think it defaults to default
probably I probably probably doesn't
default all other ones if you turn turn
it to none you save a few split seconds
for puzzle so it's a pro tip don't tell
anyone though don't tell the competition
even though you are the competition I'll
do one more wait is hammer did hammer
qualify hammer are you playing the the
qualifier thing I feel like hammer is
probably pretty good at this okay let's
do this
do this stuff meet I want to get to 40
again it felt so good when I got to 40
[Music]
well what am i doing check fork
shout-out to reddit shout-out to read it
again it someone clip that and share it
on reddit do that and that listen this
that oh oh I mean I'm scared
check check check check check
fork oh no probably just this
oh my Queens hanging though was this oh
I win back the team
okay Chuck Chuck takes promotion look
see it
Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck I have to take
and straight clean walls let's do this
no oh I had to take first terrible let's
play quani here and win the bishop okay
learn my lesson three Queen g5 or no
there's no threats or is there threats
could take on f2
[Music]
hey it's bits
what is this g4g for I mean G for each
for work h7 concise forty seconds
checking mates it's gotta be this bishop
d8 what a move
no I missed and although it was night of
three ah got too confident
g4 will be mates it's gotta be the rook
g2g you know I was Queen h3 moving a
little bit too fast
oh good job for clipping that Thank You
Carlos Carlos sake but I won the battle
nice oh but my opponents rating I want
to pay a higher rate of opponent
okay so I'll play I'll play like a slow
turn I'll play the rapid arena and I'll
I'll try and like be instructive and
answer questions but for now oh I have a
challenge I'll call places oh I have
another challenge all challenges been
canceled
I accepted hammers challenge hey I'm
playing hammer Oh scared what happened
okay playing hammer let's stay try and
stay sober for this one check check
check
I should not have told hammer my secrets
to move in quickly what does this puzzle
check ah so much stress why don't I see
it check I should teach why am I not
seeing this one I have a chat oh I have
made into I didn't see 96
ok let's catch up hammer stuck it looks
like what color my first of all have
this move from the smooth hmm trying to
catch up
what to do here h4 take takes gear okay
I almost caught up hey another son
thanks another son
you're okay for almost traps a queen
that's nice
hmm Queen here okay I'm taking Queenie
here mm-hmm
oh this is scary again not too scary
this is nice wait well we're tied 27 all
check what is this one oh he got it
wrong
let's try and get it right it's nice
okay what to do here
why am I not seeing this one feel stuck
ago king h5 nice move I have to take
just have to take no mmm
[Music]
No
all so close so close was this one also
rematch over t2 or t2 so nice so nice oh
that's rough
yeah I took so long on the knight c6
meet problem I'll be JA thanks for
subbing okay alright let's get off to a
fast start
just show him who's faster
no that starts okay I can't go to insane
[Music]
classic one that's meaning one
this is maybe to have a beat but I got
one wrong this is just a draw pin and
wind take a pawn should probably take
here actually to do first takes there
yeah let's just take and take
takes takes probably have to take the
Queen no not good
take here I already have two wrong it's
tied hmm I gotta push the pawn what else
to do
nice hey there I just move simple time
running low hmm searching
[Music]
not seeing it ah ah so close yet so far
what does this one work takes after
three pretty match ah
Quincy won in the end that's nice when
Jiwon wins a queen and what was this one
should be H five oh I just saved that
[ __ ] Oh working one working one so nice
yeah okay playing hammer again trying to
start strong Oh No can overconfidence
okay he got one wrong - that's nice
always play g5 Kochi one looks nice when
he five looks nice hmm oh just ninety
seven takes takes what does this one Oh
Queen g5 and then I check her a six
maybe six no check in 96
hmm
take some queen bee one mean c3 and take
g4 oh he got some wrong okay well I mean
try and finish strong this is nice
friend no okay okay my first my first
victory should we go again
Hey but you disagree thanks for the bits
are these ones what's this one
oh yeah the Queen was hanging but like
threatening Knights got it
any seven so we have to stop any 7 Oh
Gigi's hammer
thanks for the games okay I think we'll
we'll switch gears and the Lea chess
tournament is starting in just two
minutes
yeah Somnath chess will play another
time
thanks for hammer or thanks to hammer
for the net